what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting into superior spider-man
volume to this again is where Dan Slott
kind of goes through this phase of kind
of taking things in steps taking things
in smaller proportions here and there
really what's superior for a Spider Man
first started almost as superior Iron
Man which I really want to cover that
story at some point Oh a superior
spider-man first started there were a
lot of thoughts of people saying well
spider-man's going to come back Peter
Parker is going to come back to normal
is going to come back to being himself
and he is I mean you can't do something
like superior spider-man and get rid of
Peter Parker forever he's to intrinsic
of a superhero if you like killing off
Superman and never bringing him back
because of that we knew that Spiderman
was going to come back later on down the
line but in the interim Dan Slott and
Marvel were playing this up as though
Peter Parker was gone forever and so
while we had this subconscious aspect of
Peter Parker in the mind of his own body
despite the fact that Doctor Octopus was
basically taking control of Peter's body
in the end what the story's going to do
is basically eliminate that entire idea
and bring forward the notion that Peter
Parker is gone forever now the way this
initially picks up is it actually joins
us with a guy named dr. Elias wertham
who also goes by the name of cardiac now
cardiac is a guy who dates all the way
back to amazing spider-man number 342 in
1990 but in truth it was would just like
Elias wertham he didn't really become
cardiac until like three two or three
inches later so along those lines but
the idea here was that he was basically
a vigilante but not in the traditional
sense and that's one of the things that
made his characters interesting cardiac
was actually a God who took the law into
his own hands for the betterment of
society and so what he was doing as he
was basically fighting against criminals
he was fighting against guys like Justin
Hammer different things like that so it
wasn't really like a traditional bad guy
or traditional antihero like The
Punisher he was actually doing good
things the idea here though is that
Elias wertham is basically taking over
the heart clinic now this is one of the
reasons why I wanted to do really you
know spider-man big time going forward
because of the fact that a lot of things
that we're taking place in superior
spider-man referenced the events of
VidCon and some of them even reference
some of the events before but really big
time is all we needed since the bulk of
the references really come from Dan
slots first time taking over the series
as a solo guy but the idea here is that
Alliance for film is basically running
this sort of underground hospital and
that's kind of cool here because what we
end up finding out from the perspective
of Elias wertham one of the big issues
with modern-day hospitals is cost VI
that people go in they have pre-existing
conditions yada yada yada and it's
really dance last way of saying this is
the biggest problem with society at the
moment is that you have people who need
legitimate medical attention but they're
basically knocked down on the donors
list because they have existing
conditions or because they're just not
as high up somebody registered before
them and it's really just one of these
ideas where it is a lot of people need
more help then there is helpless
actually available and so because of
this we end up finding out that Alliance
wertham has been going through and
launching these little attacks or he's
basically been stealing supplies from
places in order to provide those people
with the help that they need
but these supplies that are being stolen
our supplies that were confiscated from
criminals so it actually kind of begs an
interesting question is he really doing
the wrong thing or is he doing the right
thing
or if you're doing the right thing for
all the wrong reasons are you doing
doing the wrong thing for all the right
reasons so because of this again it kind
of throws us in a moral quandary and
that's one of the things that I love so
much about Dan Slott superior spider-man
is it really brings a lot of moral
philosophical ideals into the equation
but we talked about that in the last
video when superior spider-man killed
Massacre if you kill one man to save a
thousand people is it the right thing to
do it's it's good old-fashioned Jeremy
Bentham you know John Stuart Mill
utilitarianism the sacrifices or I guess
the needs of the many outweigh the needs
of the few but the moral implication
here is at what point does that stop you
know we saw that with like Superman for
example topple the governments of the
world so the billions of people who
exist can live without the oppression of
government so again you know there's
there's a point at what you simply just
have to stop and that's when it comes to
the whole philosophy of you know
morality and so on and so forth it's
really the line dry now of course
because of the actions of of Elias
because of his actions you know is
cardiac breaking in the facility so on
and so forth stealing the things that he
needs what this does is it basically has
you know the the police for New York
investigating or at least alerting
alerting superior spider-man now
Whittier eyes on the scene right off the
bat he immediately attacks
Elias now again Peter Parker exists as a
sort of subconscious thought and
occasionally he can intervene and what
does he'll actually show us if he can
still influence the body and even the
mind of superior spider-man but because
of this Peter Parker's screaming in the
background look this guy is not a bad
guy he's doing all the right things or
all the wrong things for all the right
reasons
but he's trying to do good he's trying
to do what he's supposed to and so
because that's the first indication that
we get a Peter Parker being able to
influence a Peter a superior spider-man
is when he screams to stop and it's the
what just catches the attention of
superior spider-man now again these are
disembodied voices and the mind of
superior spider-man he doesn't know
what's going on all he's hearing is just
a voice somewhere telling him to stop
we'll also see here in a little while
that it'll actually a Peter Parker will
start moving his own hand at different
things like that but again this is
basically just a I guess an effect of
the two of them fighting one another but
when we end up finding out that Elias is
here to basically steer some steel
something called the neurologic scanner
which is designed to basically map the
human brain superior spider-man realizes
that as Doctor Octopus he made that
device and so in his mind
cardiac is stealing something that
inherently belongs to Doctor Octopus now
this is a funny situation because what
this does is it throws into sharp relief
the idea that despite the fact that
Doctor Octopus took over the body of
Peter Parker and is now operating as
spider-man he can't quite let his pass
to go he can't quite let go of the fact
that he was a bad guy that things that
he invented if this was a wholesale
relaunch and this was a wholesale idea
of Doctor Octopus walking away from his
past he was simply saying well you can
have it that's just my that's my past
life but the fact that he feels like it
still belongs to him he simply can't let
that go now from here it is the idea of
him trying to figure out what's going on
inside of his own mind and the idea that
Peter Parker had basically stayed his
hand despite the fact that superior
spider-man was going to kill cardiac and
so at this point it's basically superior
spider-man tagging cardiac with one of
these you know little spider tracker so
we can track his location as well as
superior spider-man going back and see
if he can't figure out what's going on
with his own body now what is up
happening here is in the middle of his
investigations he's basically contacted
by the Avengers now this is actually
kind of a funny situation because it's
basically superior spider-man versus the
Avengers and what Dan Slott did with
this is he designed this explicitly I
really wrote this explicitly for the
purpose to show us how spider-man would
stack up against the Avengers because we
haven't really had a reason to see a
story where he takes on the entirety of
the Avengers because spider-man has
always been a good guy he's always been
a guy that fought on behalf of the
Avengers but he never really fought
against them at least not as a person
who was literally trying to do them harm
and so because of this the Avengers
basically call him in and say look we've
been watching the things that you
you've taken apart heavier hand with
villains and you have in the past
you killed Massacre you almost killed
cardiac what is going on with you now of
course because of the fact they
basically want to take him to conduct a
full scan a whole battery of tests the
fear of superior spider-man as the
Avengers will figure out what's going on
with him then it'll actually figure out
that Doctor Octopus took over the body
of Peter Parker and so of course this
leads to a skirmish between these
members of the Avengers superiors firing
himself now keep in mind this is not
like a full contingent of the Avengers
but the ones who are here nothing to
laugh at I mean you've got Wolverine
with his heightened senses Captain
America with his agility you have four
you have Jessica drew Spider Woman I
mean you have some pretty formidable
guys here and of course Black Widow I
don't want to leave someone leave Black
Widow out but what is it happening here
is there's basically reference made to
the idea that Peter Parker I'm sorry
that superior spider-man I'm so used to
saying Peter Parker the superior
spider-man's spider-sense makes it
almost impossible for the Avengers to
take him out and that's the minute I
want to kind of talk about here for a
second really in my mind and for the
longest time and Sal overcoming pop will
tell you this the longest time I always
thought Peter Parker was just a stupid
character like I never liked spider-man
I was like hey look he's popular people
like him whatever I don't really care
but you know after really analyzing him
further and going through these stories
and it was well-written as a lot of
these stories aren't one of the reasons
why Peter Parker you know as spider-man
and even super you know Doctor Octopus
as superior spider-man one of the
reasons why you know he's such a
formidable hero is because of the fact
that his spider sense basically alerts
him of danger before that danger ever
happens and so he's always a step ahead
of the person that he's fighting one of
the best ways to look at this is that
the the best offense is a good defense
and so because of this you know with
superior spider-man having the ability
to know attacks that are going to happen
before they happen even if it doesn't
know exactly what the attacking person
is going to do it keeps them out of
harm's way
and so what this means is he can turn
around and routinely stay on the
offensive so long as the spider sense is
working adequately now for steel in a
moment of distraction when Peter Parker
is basically distracting Doctor Octopus
what this does is it grants the Avengers
a brief moment of reprieve which of
course we're able to use to essentially
topple him but at this point Dan Slott
kind of makes the Avengers look like
buffoons which is not something that I'm
really really on par with I mean I love
The Avengers I mean the Avengers one of
my favorite teams but to make them look
like buffoons it's not something that
I'm but I'm doing partial with but
what happens after all these different
tests Captain America says we've
confirmed you're not a scroll you're not
possessed by you know some ghost out in
space somewhere no one's taken control
of you or anything like that but in the
moment of analyzing these brain patterns
Doctor Octopus realizes that there's
brain patterns that should not be there
now he doesn't know that it's Peter
Parker all he knows is his brain the
patterns are not where they're supposed
to be and so because of this you know
while the time.she Romanoff is having
this conversation with superior
spider-man talking about the first time
she killed and how Theo the fact that
superior spider-man and killed Massacre
is going to stick with him whether he
knows it or not Peter Parker takes
control of doctor octopus's hand while
he's kind of idle and basically draws
out this little diagram indicating
that's the Doctor Octopus stole them so
the body of Peter Parker now the problem
with this is that this is a very basic
drawing and Dan Slott plays it up this
way Dan Slott plays it plays it up to us
he also that we look at this were like
well how in the heck is she supposed to
know that Doctor Octopus to control of
Peter Parker's body you know but at the
very least it would it would send off an
indication that there's something
legitimately wrong with spider-man and
so because of this you know Natasha
Romanov of course would be able to put
two and two together eventually
what does well do is kind of set or at
least a good sentence it's the
possibility out that she's going to end
up on this course or she's going to
start investigating what's actually
going on with Peter Parker now switching
back over to to cardiac of course with
Doctor Octopus superior spider-man using
the spider cracker and eventually you
know locating where he's at the two of
them engage in a skirmish once more but
in the middle of this whole fight
basically it leads into this operating
room and this is when superior
spider-man begins to realize that the
reason why cardiac is doing this is to
save the lives of people and so the
whole crux of this was that despite the
fact that he had taken a scanner from
you know that had previously been built
by Doctor Octopus cardiac did not know
how to use it in its entirety and so
what this does is it basically sets the
stage for Dan Slott to continue superior
spider-man down the role of being a good
guy when he looks at this and says well
I'm the one who designed this machine I
know how it works better than anybody
else I can literally help fix this girl
and I can turn around and perform the
surgery myself and so of course again
because of the catch this was completed
the little girl is saved
it basically continues this trend of
superior spider-man becoming a good guy
and so taking that machine back to his
lab and then investigating further he
directly acknowledges Peter Parker
look I now realize you're the voice
inside my head I now realize that I
didn't take over your body and its
entirety that you know for some reason
or another your consciousness is still
there now after doing a little more
investigating after that what we find
out is that the this essence of Peter
Parker that's talking to dr. octopus is
basically an amalgamation of his
memories in the sense that as long as
dr. octopus uses the memories of Peter
Parker Peter Parker's essence will
always be there and this is really damn
slot essentially saying that we as
people are effectively just a
combination of all our experiences
everything that makes us who we are are
the things that we've been through and
so because of that Peter will always be
alive so long as his memories aren't
there and so dr. octopus takes the most
logical step and simply says we have to
purge these memories from my mind now
this was actually a really really really
cool segment of the story because this
pits Peter Parker and dr. octopus
against one another in a way that hasn't
really been seen before routinely
speaking when these guys go against one
another they just kind of fight I mean
it's really just a fight in the city and
you know it goes on for a little while
and innocents are put in danger you know
Peter Parker defeats Doctor Octopus
Doctor Octopus goes away for a little
while he manages to break out and then
it starts all over again it's pretty par
for the course you can set your watch to
the fights between Peter Parker and his
rogues gallery but what this does is
that introduces a new dynamic because
what they're doing is they're fighting
inside the mind of Peter Parker's body
and so what this does is it creates a
pretty even playing field between the
two of them a Peter Parker basically
draws on all the people who have served
significant roles in his life Uncle Ben
Aunt May friends and family different
things like that and while this does
allow him to get a little bit of the
upper hand
it is Dan slosh saying a little bit hey
look the most important thing that we
have in life are friends and family but
the other half of this equation is that
doctor Doctor Octopus himself is not
without his own friends now when I say
friends of Doctor Octopus when I say
family of dr. octopus I used that term
loosely these various villains that
Octus fought behind her fought beside
over the course of the years I wouldn't
really consider to be like legitimate
friends or legitimate family not by any
stretch of the imagination but they're
the closest thing he has not only that
all these guys are formidable in their
own right and so in truth it comes down
to a pretty significant battle between
the two of them but in the end Doctor
Octopus ends up winning out now the
reason why this is the case is twofold
the first is that it is people with
superpowers going against individuals
without superpowers but this is also Dan
Slott offering a meta commentary that
the people finding on being on behalf of
Peter Parker are only as strong as Peter
Parker is for himself that is to say
their reflection of the faith that Peter
Parker has in himself
only if he is a strong individual only
if he legitimately believes that he
should be spider-man do these
individuals have any measure of power
ticking that Doctor Octopus but in the
end he doesn't think that he deserves to
be spider-man and the reason why is
because of a conversation between the
two of them as this fight starts to
dwindle down and it just turns into
superior spider-man versus the amazing
spider-man Doctor Octopus makes an
incredibly good point what happened here
was that when when when superior
spider-man was in the process of getting
ready to perform the surgery on that
young girl Peter Parker did not want him
to do it he kept making his handshake
and the reason why was because Peter
Parker did not believe that Doctor
Octopus would have the skill to save
this young girl's life
what Doctor Octopus says here is you
were willing to let this girl die in
order to get your body back you are
willing to sacrifice an innocent in
order to sea in order to defeat me
Doctor Octopus making the case that what
Peter Parker did was tantamount to
Doctor Octopus holding someone hostage
and then Peter Parker shooting the
hostage in order to kill Doctor Octopus
that's the case that's being made here
and because of that in face of that
Peter Parker has a total breakdown he
says oh my god you're right I was
willing to sacrifice the life of an
innocent young girl in order to make
sure that you were defeated but you were
stopped the other half of this was that
Doctor Octopus says look I was trying to
do the right thing so not only were you
willing to put an innocent in danger you
were going to stop me from doing
something good you were going to become
a bad guy because you didn't like what
it was that I was doing you didn't trust
me and so because of this Doctor Octopus
basically initiates this Mindwipe a
Peter Parker has no no more defense
really nothing to put up against this
and so all these different memories of
Peter Parker start getting wiped away
and what this does is it sets the next
stage the next phase of the story which
is simply Doctor Octopus
in the body of Peter Parker without
having to worry about his essence or his
memories causing any kind of problems
for him in the foreseeable future but
with that being said guys we're going to
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new
here to comment explain make sure you
guys to the sub when did become part of
the Rob Corp you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you guys on it please
[Music]
you